so congratulations on season four you
know fans of marvelous mrs maisel have
been waiting for two years their turn of
the show did you feel rusty at all you
know that first day back on set for
season four rachel
yeah definitely
we've been sitting in our in our houses
and sweatpants and and shoeless for you
know nearly two years and
and uh it was a it was a bit of a rough
transition to put all these for me
anyway to put all these clothes and
heels and course it back on but i think
tony said it best which was they were
doing a really complicated scene on the
first day and most of my stuff was off
camera and tony tony came up at one
point and was like it's like the words
are coming out but my brain is two beats
behind them i think mostly we were just
a little slow for you know for a couple
episodes but but we figured it out and
i'm sure that they helped us in the edit
amazing alex how easy was it for you to
get back into you know the quick
dialogue because both of you your scenes
together are so funny the chemistry
between you two is just so great to
watch how easy was it for you to get
back into the group of things
well it's the opposite for me i was home
i wear corsets and heels home and when i
get on that i relax into my
my uh dungarees um it was very difficult
it was hard to get back into the rhythm
of things and just be
waking up at a certain time and i know
and talking to adults you know i had
been locked in away and quarantined with
children and homeschooling and
so it was it was very very different
getting getting back into the role and
and we were both very worried we kept
saying like i forgot how to act
i don't know if this is even working is
this the character is this the voice and
you know it's kind of lucky that you
have a scene partner in that regard to
tell you yeah yeah no that that's midge
i recognize that yeah
rachel did it take a little bit to get
used to your really fancy umbrella loved
seeing the pictures of you on set i mean
it was like a contraption
it really was at first it was very
exciting at first it was the new
innovation that meant that you know we'd
all been in masks for so long and and we
just realized that mine was lifting the
the lace on my wig around my ears and so
a very inventive team got to work and
made this thing and at first i was like
oh incredible this is so great and then
um by the end of the season i wanted to
throw it into the hudson so
uh i didn't uh
but um
but
first they first made it where you had
to hold it and then she was like i can't
look at my lines i can't drink coffee so
then they tried to make some kind of a
harness where it stuck on her and
it looked like she you know like joan
cusack with the scoliosis character and
whatever that like it just looked insane
it was like a jellyfish with a neck
brace and i was not able to get
paparazzi in a new york city like that
so we went then we went back to the home
and then they built one that went around
the chair it was a unprecedented time i
love that um you know what's so great
about midge for the last three seasons
just watching you know her career just
catapult and then all of a sudden we
watch it all come crumbling down how
does she handle kind of going back to
the beginning when we pick up in season
four
yeah and i think it's susie who says
we're back to square one and yes and no
you know they are sort of but they've
also had
all of this experience together and so
i think they know they know what they
have to do they know
how to work together to rebuild even if
they don't know exactly how to get there
um but it's a real make it or break it
moment for them i think they they have
seen
all of their dreams and ambitions
evaporate in a puff of smoke
and um
or tail tail wind whatever you know on a
plane it went off in the sky
and uh and they are they're taking a
hard look at each other and figuring out
you know they have nothing to lose and
everything to gain so what do they
really want
oh that's a good way of describing that
how does susie handle all this because
obviously she has her own issues going
on money and there's just her whole life
has just imploded as well
again i mean susie's never had anything
so even more so than mid she's got
absolutely nothing to lose the only
thing she has now is this responsibility
to me
you know at the end of that season she
says it's gonna be okay we're gonna be
okay and
i don't even if she she has no idea how
but she's gonna
as god as her witness make it so and she
immediately in this season starts
scrambling to
make herself stronger to give herself a
stronger foundation to be able to hold
midge up and that means diversifying
that means trying to create a bigger
business get more clients
and put the associates in susie myerson
and associates
yeah i love that yeah right to work you
can see that from episode one and season
four um rachel was really excited to
hear that your husband was joining
season four
uh what was it like having him on set is
that nerve-wracking is that exciting
well i without giving anything away we
uh never were on set together at the
same time so okay
so it was um it was actually it was kind
of it was fun it was fun for
for him to get an inside look at where
i've been when i've missed every uh
every dinner and and dog walk over the
last couple of years
um
but yeah i mean it was it was a blast
that's so cool i was on set with him
quite a bit so i think it's scary i
think i scared him
on many equations uh
but but we had a good time he's he's a
very talented guy so it was it was a
pleasure that's rachel did you hear that
alex here jason at all
i i'm sure she tried her best
she probably succeeded
i think i think he was maybe not going
to tell me in great detail about that
part i love that so much well listen
gilmore girl fans are just over the moon
that milo ventimiglia is joining this
season alex what was it like having him
on set
oh it was wonderful he plays my love
interest
yay fan service oh
why are you laughing morgan why is that
funny
oh my gosh i want this to be a real
thing
yeah we're we're we fall deeply in love
and the rest is herstory you'll see for
yourself
that's awesome
um so i have to tell you one of my
favorite scenes between you two actually
in the whole series is when you're in
the cab in the first episode and you
jump out and you're fighting each other
did you did you make it through the
whole scene without laughing i mean i
was dying it wasn't like shooting that
scene there was no laughing no laughter
it was very late and very cold
yeah oh
that makes sense
for a number of hours before we actually
shot it because most of that scene is in
one shot
and so by the time we actually shot it
we were bruised and exhausted alex packs
a mean punch
it's almost a physical very physical
scene and uh yeah we it was the weekend
and i was going out of town and the next
day woke up and like this whole side of
my hand was bruised
you'll just
see why folks yeah it's so good and just
wrapping things up you know we're
hearing that uh
uh lenny bruce is gonna have more of a
presence this season rachel anything you
can tease us about midge and lenny
because as you know fans cannot get
enough their chemistry
yeah i'm gonna steal something that that
luke has been saying because i think it
sums it up pretty well without getting a
lot away which is that obviously you
know lenny bruce is a real person and we
do have an obligation to you know to
honor the real person that lenny was and
and also
uh have introduced him into this
fictional space in this relationship
with midge
and he's served as somewhat of a of a
fairy godmother presence over the last
couple of seasons um he's someone that
she holds up on the highest pedestal and
in a lot of ways is modeling herself
after
and you know what what goes up must come
down at some point so i think you're
you're going to see a more grounded
version
of lenny this season and how that
impacts their relationship
that's exciting alex rachel thanks so
much for your time already from what
i've seen from season four it's so good
thank you
you